What is the best sort of life for a
human being?
Socrates claimed in 400 BC that a man
lives a happier life if he's just,
even if he's thrown starving into prison
for the rest of his life,
then if he's unjust and he celebrated
and honored all of his days and his
never caught for his crimes,
could that possibly be correct?
If not,
why not?
And what difference should the question
make to us?
Now?
What moves the human heart?
Shakespeare's characters throw us into
the depths of lust,
envy,
greed,
pride,
ambition.
What are those characters have to say
about the way that we act or that we
behave or that we believe?
And if so,
what difference would it make to read
about them in Shakespeare?
Why Shakespeare,
who is Elizabeth and English is very
difficult for us who speak moderating
which to understand Thomas Hobbs road in
1651 a book called Leviathan,
one of the two or three most influential
works in the history of thinking about
government and politics in Western
society.
He was writing from the midst of a
raging civil war and he argued that
unless we gave all the power,
unless we surrendered all ultimate
control to a legitimate king,
that we would all rob and kill each
other.
Was He right about that?
Is that the way things actually work and
is the question relevant to us today
when we no longer believe in kings?
Hello,
my name is Jeff Brenzel and I'm the dean
of undergraduate admissions at Yale
University.
I lecture from time to time in the
philosophy department at Yale and my
work in philosophy centers around ethics
and also the history of the ideas that
we've had about something we'd like to
call human nature.
Speaking of human nature,
one of my personal heroes,
aristotle claimed that by nature
everyone seeks to know everyone desires
to know.
For the purposes of this talk,
I'm going to assume that you are already
an intellectually curious person and
that you're not only chasing after
knowledge as hard as you can.
You're also trying to build up the skill
sets and acquire the kind of capacities
and abilities that you're going to need
to become a better learner overall.
If these things are in fact about you,
then here's my advice in a nutshell.
Make a choice in college to read some
old books,
even a substantial number of old books.
My argument will be that reading the
right old books in the right way is
better than reading only new books,
much less using only new ways of
learning that have nothing to do with
books at all.
But let's be careful about what I'm
claiming and what I'm not claiming.
I'm not claiming that you should read
only all books,
uh,
or that old books are better because
they're old.
Uh,
or that you should never read any new
books or that new books are worthless.
Only that you should read and learn how
to read some old books,
but which ones would those be?
How do you learn how to read them in the
right way?
Why should you read them in college and
how could doing that change your life
for the better?
How is that going to make you smarter?
And Moreover,
how's it going to make you wiser?
The dialogues of socrates,
Aristotle's ethics,
oedipus rex,
the city of God,
Leviathan,
Dante's inferno,
King Lear,
Paradise Lost Warren piece.
There are a lot of these books,
but why spend a significant amount of
your time on books that by definition
are outdated?
Why not go after the books that bring
everything up to date?
Don't we know everything those people
already knew and much,
much more.
So a little personal background here.
I went off to university in 1971 no one
in my family had ever graduated from
college,
much less a place like Yale.
I had never visited across the state
line.
I never reviewed,
had even been on an airplane before.
The one that swept me off to uh,
to new haven,
Connecticut.
Now when I actually showed up at Yale,
I applied in total ignorance and almost
by accident to a special freshman year
program called directed studies.
So what is directed studies and directed
studies?
You take three full year courses in the
history of Western thought and
philosophy and literature and in
politics,
you start with what the classic Greeks
had to say,
and then you roll forward with the
centuries until you end up about a
century behind where we are right now.
There is no textbooks,
there's no summaries,
there's no cliff notes.
You read only the original works.
And it was both the single most
difficult and the single most
transforming educational experience that
I've ever had.
About 15 years ago,
I came back to Yale after founding
companies managing organizations,
uh,
and after earning a phd in philosophy.
And I'm having the opportunity there
today to teach in this very same program
that I took over 30 years ago.
So I've gotten to know these classic
works fairly well,
have become familiar with them.
Uh,
I've seen their effects on students,
um,
and I've had the chance to stack them up
against my own life experience and stuff
that I've read from lots of modern
books.
So here I am ready to give you some good
reasons to look into the classics
yourself.
Now,
the first thing to point out is
something that I think you already know.
There are a lot of books out there and
you don't have much time.
The Library of Congress has over 20
million volumes.
That's the largest library in the world.
That's not counting the journals,
the publications.
It's not counting the Internet.
It's not counting the blogs.
It's not counting with wikipedia is not
counting the entire Google plex.
Meanwhile,
down here on the personal level,
I'm 58 years old.
I've been a pretty strong reader for
about 40 years.
Uh,
back home,
I've got a personal library of about
2000 books,
volumes.
And if you do the math,
that's about 50 books times 40 years,
50 books a year.
It's about a book a week.
I hope you can see the problem.
My problem,
which is also your problem,
which is we ain't gonna make it through
the library of Congress.
Not only that,
we're not going to get to 99.99,
nine,
9% of everything that's ever been
written.
You know,
Mahatma Gandhi said,
live as though you'll die tomorrow,
but learn as though you'll live forever.
Gandhi was as aware as you and I are
that we're not going to live forever.
And of course,
um,
that means that you are going to have to
be extremely picky about what you choose
to read.
Even if you live according to Gandhi,
you literally have no other choice.
But now it seems I've only made my job
harder because I've got to persuade you
that with this precious time that you
have for learning and study,
which is dwindling all the time,
uh,
that you're going to take some of it and
devote it to things that are.
Um,
so let's focus on the principle of
necessity.
And that means the principle of having
to make these difficult and time
consuming choices.
I'd like to give you five reasons,
five rough and ready criteria for
identifying a classic of literature or
philosophy or politics.
Now,
no one or two of these criteria are
going to be decisive,
but I think if you put them all
together,
they're going to prove actually to be
quite useful first.
The work addresses a permanent universal
concern about the human condition.
From the philosophical perspective,
it has something to say about the way we
should live from a literary perspective.
It helps us imagine different ways that
we could live and from a political
perspective or an historical
perspective,
it helps us remember ways that we have
lived.
So that's Martin number one of a classic
Martin.
Number two is that the work has been a
game changer.
It changed perspective or shifted
perspective on those issues both for the
earliest people who read the book and
also for those who came later.
Martin.
Number three is that the work has
stimulated or provoked or responded to
many other important works.
Martin.
Number four is that many generations of
the very best readers and the most
expert critics have rated the work
highly is one of the best and most
important of its kind.
Even if those reviewers,
those experts didn't agree on anything
else and even if they took our head a
violent argument with the work itself.
Martin,
number five is that the work usually
does require a strenuous effort to both
engage it and understand it.
But rewards that great effort in
multiple ways and very highly.
Before we think about what these
criteria rule in,
let's think about what they rule out.
Let's say that you run up to me with a
novel that you picked up just last week.
You waving in the air and you say,
Professor Brenzel,
I've got a great book here for you.
It's an instant classic,
even better than Moby Dick,
maybe even better than moby Dick.
What am I likely to respond?
Well,
it may be in fact very good and your
recommendation may persuade me to read
it,
particularly if I have a high opinion of
you as an expert reader.
Your new favorite book May in fact
become a classic someday,
but
it hasn't changed.
The game is yet for other writers and
readers,
it hasn't provoked or influenced lots of
other works.
How could it,
you don't know how experts and other
readers are going to evaluate it over
time.
You're not even sure how you're going to
see the book over time,
but let's remember the critical problem
that we all have way too many books and
not nearly enough time.
So,
where are you likely to get the biggest
bang for your reading dollar and for
your reading hour,
something published last week or
something that stood the centuries of
tests by tough readers and that has in
fact spawned a great deal of what you'll
be reading today.
So I'm sort of defining a classic as an
old book.
It's been through generations of
readers,
big game,
changing ideas,
uh,
and something that you can expect to
find to be a considerable challenge to
tackle.
So let's flush it out with just a few
examples,
uh,
before we talk about what good it's
going to do.
You to read such a book in a college
course.
Socrates was a philosopher who lived in
Athens,
ancient Greece about 400 years before
the birth of Christ.
You've probably heard his name,
even if you know nothing else about him,
you may also know that the other
citizens of Athens put him to death.
Uh,
because he went around asking a lot of
challenging questions,
needling people,
irritating them,
uh,
with questions about their actions and
their beliefs that they didn't care to
answer.
Well,
it's a remarkable fact that for the past
24 centuries,
very few thinkers in the western
tradition have been able to avoid having
to come at some point to grips with
socrates and his life and his death.
It's even more interesting that
socrates,
so far as we know,
never actually wrote down a single word.
He strolled around the town,
uh,
embarrassing prominent people with his
questions.
He liked to say that the only
superiority that he ever claimed was
that he was absolutely certain that he
was ignorant,
but he found that people believe that
they knew all kinds of things and in
that he was superior to them.
Now,
one of the young aristocrats who got a
big charge out of,
uh,
following socrates around the town was a
young wrestler named Plato,
maybe the first scholar athlete.
So Plato wrote a series of dialogues
after socrates died that featured his
hero and the principal role,
the early dialogues,
uh,
do seem to reflect for us this business
of walking around asking these difficult
questions that no one can answer.
Later in the later dialogues,
Plato begins to use socrates as a
mouthpiece or as someone who represents
the kinds of new questions that plato
himself began to ask under socrates
inspiration to give me some indication
of how expert readers over time have
understood Plato's thought and its
central importance in the tradition.
The great 20th century philosopher and
mathematician Alfred North Whitehead
once said that all of western thought is
nothing more than a series of footnotes
to Plato.
Quite a claim and remember that it was
Plato's encounter was socrates that
inspired all of Plato's thought.
Now,
Plato's single most important dialogue
with socrates is the hero is a dialog
called the republic.
And in it,
Plato tries to formulate to basic
fundamental and universal questions.
What's the best sort of life for a human
being?
And beyond that,
what's the best society for producing
the conditions under which human beings
could live that kind of life?
These two questions give the book the
first mark of greatness that I was,
um,
that I was discussing,
which is the republic addresses
permanent and universal questions.
Ones that might puzzle you as much as
they did socrates.
And Plato.
The book opens with a really terrific
argument about justice,
whether it's the just or the unjust
person who gets the better of it in
life.
Software confronts a very sarcastic and
very aggressive young man named
[inaudible] who attacks the common
notion that justice is a virtue.
Listen then says through civicus I
proclaim that might is right.
And that justice,
as you call it,
is whatever happens to be in the
interest of the stronger.
There are different forms of government,
but they all make laws according to
their own interests.
Everywhere.
There is only one principle of so called
justice,
which is that justice turns out to be
whatever happens to be in the interest
of the stronger.
So have you ever heard someone make this
argument before?
That might makes right?
The justice has no fixed meaning that
what is considered just in a society is
just whatever the people running the
society say it is.
I'd be surprised if you hadn't,
because it's a universally recurring
argument,
not only throughout the dorms have any
good colleges down through time,
uh,
but also down through the centuries in
the debates of the very best
philosophers.
Now I can't do justice in this short
talk to even this relatively simple
opening framing argument of the republic
for Simica Socrates.
But essentially socrates tries to answer
it through civicus by pointing out that
we distinguished between good rulers and
bad rulers.
Just like we distinguish between good
shepherds and bad shepherds or good boat
captains and bad boat captains.
The good shepherds act in the best
interests of the sheep and the good boat
captains act in the best interest of
their boats and passengers.
So a ruler,
if he's right,
we named a ruler or she's rightly named
a ruler,
is someone who acts in the best interest
of the subjects and the bad ones don't
throw synagis calls this drivel.
He points out that the shepherd hardly
cares for the sheep.
He simply fattening them for the
slaughter.
Consider further,
most foolish socrates.
He says that the just is always a loser
and comparison with the unjust.
First of all in private matters,
wherever the unjust is the partner of
the just,
you will find that the unjust man always
gains more and the just man always gets
less.
Next in their dealings with the
government when there is an income tax,
the just man will pay more and the
unjust man less on the same amount of
income and when there is anything to be
received,
the one gains nothing.
The other gains much
okay.
By this standard for semigloss goes on
to say the best life is actually the one
to be had by the absolute tyrant who can
take anything that he wishes by force
and make everyone else pay honor and
obedience.
So not only is being a tyrant the best
kind of life,
all people would become tyrants if only
they could know.
Socrates at this point,
Knox through simic is down with some
verbal and logical tricks that I'm not
going to take you through in this talk
and outwitted through Simica stocks off
from the conversation,
not to return.
The young friends of socrates are not
satisfied with this outcome.
And they take up the core question,
but in a much harder for them.
They asked socrates to prove to them
that the just person is always happier
and always has a better life than the
unjust person.
No matter how poor,
deprived,
disgraced,
or reviled the just man might be.
And no matter how wealthy,
honored,
and completely unharmed an unjust man
might be.
So the rest of the republic is Plato is
attempt to answer this question along
with a number of other questions.
In the course of it,
he draws a surprisingly compelling
picture of human psychology.
He,
on the nature of knowledge,
he presents a proposal for the ideal
state and he polishes it all off with a
theory about enlightenment and about the
ultimate nature of reality.
Along the way,
he speculates about the relations
between men and women,
how to raise and educate children to be
good citizens and the right way for
human beings to investigate questions of
all kinds.
Now,
Plato himself had a brilliant student
named aristotle who for my money,
uh,
actually surpass plato and a number of
different ways,
but was certainly heavily influenced by
Plato.
So let me just give you a very quick
notion of how things play out and the
history of thought for Plato's and
Aristotle's thinking and in fact,
for your own
first,
they're thinking stays very much alive
in Greece,
in Rome for 400 years until the coming
of Christ and beyond that for many
centuries more if you happen to be a
Christian,
what you think of is Christianity.
The very concepts and ideas that form
the basis for Christianity actually turn
out to owe a great deal to plato and
Aristotle.
Virtually everything that Christianity
teaches about God,
about human nature,
about human fulfillment arises from what
the historians of religion like to call
the marriage of Jerusalem and Athens.
That is the marriage of Greek and Jewish
thinking.
One big moment for this process comes
about eighth centuries after Plato and
Aristotle for centuries after Christ,
when a man named Saint Augustan writes a
truly monumental work in the history of
Western thought.
A real classic,
the city of God.
He writes this book just as the Roman
Empire is collapsing around his ears
from invasions of barbarians.
Augustan was very influenced by platonic
thinking,
even though he wasn't all that familiar
directly with Plato's works,
and he sets the course of Christian
thinking for a very long time.
In fact,
if you're knowledgeable about the
history of Christian doctrine or
Christian theology,
uh,
you'll know that augustine is
influential right up to the current
moment.
Then another 800 years after Sandy
Gustin,
a priest around the year 1215 named
Thomas Aquinas rediscovers,
many of the last works of Aristotle.
To put this very briefly,
he puts together the thought of
Aristotle with the thought of Augustan
comes up with a new synthesis for
Christian thinking,
and it turns out to be a game changer.
The result is for the most part,
what the Roman Catholic Church teaches
to this very day,
Saint Thomas Aquinas,
the primary Orthodox theologian of
Catholicism.
Meanwhile,
the Italian poet,
Dante,
who lives one generation after aquinas
reads aquinas is influenced by his work.
And as one of the three or four greatest
poets ever to live,
presents us with his own view of human
nature,
fulfillment,
and human destiny.
When he writes his three epic poems
about Hell,
Purgatory and heaven,
uh,
you've probably heard of Dante's
inferno.
So now fast forward another 250 years
and we come to about the year 1500
Martin Luther in Germany.
Now,
luther gets very angry about a lot of
things that are happening in the
Catholic church.
He goes back and rips aquinas apart.
He trashes aristotle and he returns for
his inspiration to the game changing
works of Saint Augustine and Saint Paul.
By doing this,
luther also starts a process that
splitters Christianity into a million
pieces,
game changers.
Another hundred or so years after
luther,
we have John Milton.
Milton is an English poet.
He takes his inspiration from the
reforming of Christianity,
the Protestant reformation,
and he writes the greatest epic poem in
the English language.
Paradise lost.
It gives his own picture of the
Protestant picture of human nature,
human history,
human destiny,
God's will.
So if you happen to be a Catholic and
you believe that the Catholic Church
teaches the same thing always in
everywhere and has from the very
beginning,
or if you're an evangelical Protestant
and you believe that all of your own
views come directly from a plane,
a straight forward reading of New
Testament texts.
In either case,
you could not be more mistaken.
The very teachings of the Catholic
Church or the very ways that a
Protestant Christian interprets the
words of the Bible and scripture results
from speculations and collisions taking
place among ideas that involve plato,
aristotle,
Augustan,
Aquinas,
St Paul,
Dante,
Martin Luther,
and Milton.
Here's a very small example of something
quite specific.
Many Christians believe that Satan,
the devil,
was once a great arcane joe in fact,
that he was the highest of all the
angels and that his name was Lucifer,
and that he rebelled against God in
heaven before the creation of the entire
world.
Later,
he successfully tempted our first
parents and Adam and eve to eat an apple
in the garden of Eden.
There's actually remarkably little in
the Hebrew scriptures about Satan and
what's there does not happen to include
these beliefs.
The same as we imagine him is actually a
much later invention.
And he's not thought of as either a
fallen angel or even fully identify with
the serpent in the garden who tempt Adam
and eve to taste the fruit until four
centuries after the life of Christ.
Augustan has a lot to do with who Satan
becomes and the picture that you
yourself may have in your mind of a
rebel angel,
a war in heaven between the good angels
and the bad angels.
Well,
that's something that John Melton,
imagine for us when he published
paradise loss in 1667,
socrates and Plato and aristotle exert
influences in many other threads or
conversations or discussions that are
taking place in the western history of
ideas.
For instance,
the encounter was socrates enters very
strongly into soren kierkegaard is work
in the 19th century.
Kierkegaard is the Godfather of
existentialism.
Uh,
ultimately kierkegaard produces all
these other philosophers like heidegger
and Sartre.
Socrates also provoked and gave shape.
Um,
in an encounter,
a philosophical encounter,
uh,
gave shape to Friedrich Nietzsche's
thought also in the 19th century as
Nietzsche actually seeks to try to undo
a what he considers to be the disaster
that socrates has bequeath to Western
civilization.
So you simply cannot study the history
of western thought without running into
Plato and socrates just around about
every corner.
You can't,
uh,
read a thinker who hasn't been
influenced himself or herself by these
ideas in some way,
as well as the way that they actually
pose the original questions.
What's the best sort of life for human
being?
Uh,
and what's the best kind of society in
which that sort of life can be lived.
So the republic is still what I would
call a living book.
It's still fuels and counters.
It's still provokes us,
provokes,
uh,
students in my classroom.
I think just as much as socrates
provoked them,
uh,
in the streets of ancient Greece.
Uh,
it has something to teach us.
It has something to connect us very
deeply to the ideas of many others.
Uh,
it's something that's made our society
in some very deep respects what it is.
He might say that Plato,
uh,
and his inspiration,
soccer teas are the opposite
of outdated thinkers
on this.
Um,
rather a quick dash through the
centuries.
Uh,
I've not forgotten the question that I'm
supposed to answer,
which is,
so what,
why does it do you any good to know
these things?
What's all this about strenuous effort
and what's that got to do with something
being a classic?
Aren't there any classics that are easy
to read,
uh,
or to cut to the chase and regarding all
of the strenuous effort?
Why do I really have to dig in to
Plato's Republic at all?
Why can't I just hear about it from you?
Or why can't I read the cliff notes
version?
Or why can't I find a summary or a
digest or look on my neighbor's notes?
Um,
why won't wikipedia tell me everything
that is truly important for me to take
away from the book?
Why can't I take the,
take advantage of the fact that all
these other people have read it or
commented on it and used it for some
purpose or another?
What's the takeaway?
Well,
the 20th century philosopher and critic
Mortimer Adler,
uh,
put it this way,
the path of true learning is strewn with
rocks,
not roses,
but I am still saying he goes on that
the great books can be read by every
person.
In one sense.
Of course they are the most difficult to
read,
but they are in another sense the most
readable both for the less and the more
competent reader because they are the
most instructive.
What Adler is,
uh,
is trying to tell us here,
um,
is that uh,
just because something is difficult
doesn't mean that the time you spend
with it is not worthwhile.
And in fact that any amount of time that
you spend with one of these kinds of
works will actually be more valuable to
you then the same amount of time that
you spend on homework of lesser quality.
But,
uh,
what Adler wants us to understand a is
the principle of no pain,
no gain.
And in fact that in the case of,
uh,
works of the mind that,
whatever the pain you experience,
whatever time and study that you're
going to give to these works,
these works pay a greater return.
You might say they have a higher
interest rate,
uh,
then the ordinary stocks and bonds that
you're going to be exposed to and the
rest of your courses.
So what I'm going to do now is to try to
give you five takeaways,
uh,
that is five valuable things that are
specific to you,
uh,
that you can pull out of these books and
take away with you to the other things
that you're studying and also to your
own life.
Number one,
the value of forgotten ideas.
Some old ideas are not actually
outdated.
The entire period that we call the
European renaissance actually consisted
of people rediscovering a bunch of ideas
from the ancient world and giving them a
new application.
So point number one is some of these old
ideas are actually valuable.
Number two,
the value of making connections between
ideas.
There is less new under the sun than
what you might think.
And seeing the connections that tie one
thinker to another in a tradition,
uh,
also gives you a measure of how far
we've come on some problems and what
problems seem to have heavily resisted,
uh,
the attempts of human beings to give
them answers.
Um,
the one that we've been considering from
time to time through the course of this
talk is one of those,
what's the best sort of life for a human
being?
This is a question that you'll be asking
yourself as you try to figure out things
like where am I going to get a job?
Where am I going to live?
Who am I going to marry?
How am I going to raise my children?
Um,
these are questions that are permanent
aspects of the human condition.
You're also going to discover that this
is not the kind of question in which
science has suddenly dl,
you know,
delivered a fantastic new answer.
People have been asking and answering
this question for a long time and
looking at some old thinkers can see you
can help you see the connections between
the ways people originally asked these
questions and the way we do.
But also give you a perspective on
what's been solved,
which in some of these cases is very
little.
Um,
and uh,
what remains for you to consider an
actually,
um,
determine by the way that you live your
own life.
The third thing is that great books of
the past are going to engage you with a
number of great minds who don't share
any of your assumptions.
Just as we were talking about with
Plato,
it's a different culture,
a different morality of different
religion,
a different politics call this,
the value of strangeness,
which is not only an additional
perspective on what you believe,
uh,
but I'm going to claim is also a primary
source of human creativity.
The fourth value is quite frankly,
the value of building up your
intellectual muscle power.
You don't get to be a better wrestler by
a wrestling all the little kids in your
neighborhood and beating them up and
sending them home crying.
Uh,
if you're going to be a better wrestler,
you're going to have to get your own
nose bloody by going up against people
who are bigger and stronger and better
than you are.
So finally,
five,
there is the value of forming better
judgments.
Once you've encountered with the best of
all and wrestle them to the ground,
you're going to be much better position
to make your own good discerning
judgments about where to spend your
precious time without having past
generations of experts to do the reading
you might say ahead of you and post the
signs without knowing how a book is
going to influence other books and,
uh,
without,
yourself being able to figure,
um,
what the,
uh,
what the views are going to be of this
book in the future.
Uh,
you will be able to tell junk from gold
trash from something that's worthwhile.
Why?
Because you'll know when you're actually
up against,
uh,
a real mind.
You will have experienced the best that
we know.
So let's dig down a little bit into the
value of some old and outdated ideas.
A man named malthus in 1798 published a
classic work in political economy.
It's called an essay in the principle of
population.
Now,
the basic idea is that populations can
only grow up to the point where they
necessarily collapsed because of limited
resources,
a famine and disease.
But the essay explores the ideas and a
lot of very interesting ways.
And actually it was a major influence on
Charles Darwin and the development of
the theory of evolution.
Despite the game changing nature of this
work,
economists and scientists of the
industrial age have generally held that
malthus was fraud.
Why?
Because he predicted we were all going
to die back in the 18th century.
He thought that we were going to outrun
the food sources with our population,
uh,
and that nothing could stop a headlong
rush over the cliff.
What he did not take into proper account
were the game changing aspects of human
ingenuity and creativity that would find
a way around resource bottlenecks.
Now during the oil shocks of the 1970s.
And if you go back and look for this,
uh,
you'll see that the ideas of malthus
came very much back into view.
Why?
Because people were seeing resources
begin to run out.
The world's population had doubled over
a period of about 30 to 60 years and it
was going to going to be set to double
again.
So Thomas Malthus and his ideas about
what happens when you increase the
population past the carrying load came
around for more currency.
Today.
If you google the name Malthus,
you're going to get over 3 million hits
on the Internet.
His fundamental ideas are once again at
the center of debates about peak oil,
environmental damage,
global population,
the prospects for global catastrophe,
Malik doozy and ideas are everywhere and
his work being invoked as people wonder
if the world is about to prove mouth
this right in the end.
Okay,
here's another example of old ideas
being mined for new insights in ancient
Greece.
Aristotle wrote a book called when the
comic can ethics or for short the
ethics,
it's actually a book about human
happiness and about what it takes to be
a happy person.
Now,
we don't ordinarily associate the idea
of ethics with a work on happiness.
We think about ethics as being things
like moral obligations,
duties,
um,
what were,
what were called upon to perform.
Despite our desires to do other things.
Aristotle had a different perspective on
this.
He was an original proponent of the idea
and you may have heard this idea that
virtue is its own reward.
Then in fact,
the things that make you an excellent
parent,
th th the the things that make you an
excellent citizen are also the things if
pursued consciously and done well,
make you a happy human being.
In other words,
that there's a dedication to excellence.
We're excellence consists of the virtues
that are required for us to live well
and do well with one another.
Uh,
that is the foundation for human beings
to be happy.
This goes these days by the name virtue
ethics and philosophers and
psychologists all over the world are
studying what makes for human happiness.
Aristotle actually has something
extremely contemporary to contribute to
that debate.
So again,
reading these works gives you a very
different sense of what progress
consists of in one whole area of human
thought.
And even our notion of progress might
mean when we start to talk about
something like human happiness are,
they're really new messages coming from
the,
uh,
from the cosmos about what it takes to
be happy.
Okay.
My third value or take away,
uh,
involved what I call the value of
strangeness.
Now,
this one's a little harder to explain.
So let me use an analogy.
You've probably traveled.
People like to travel.
Some people travel a great deal.
What do people feel like they learned
from traveling,
particularly travel to another society?
One of the things that good travelers,
people who have done this well and spend
enough time in a foreign society to
really learn something about it,
they generally say that they're struck
by the ways that,
that society is different from our own.
And they're struck by the kinds of
answers that people give to questions
that,
uh,
we suddenly discover.
We've made a lot of assumptions about
that is we've made an assumption about
our lifestyle or an assumption about
what people want out of life or an
assumption about how people are going to
get those things that actually isn't an
operating in this other society at all.
And of course it might make us stop and
think,
is our way of doing this actually the
best way of doing it?
Might I pick up some ideas from this
other place?
Well,
great books can have some of this same
effect through the value of strangeness.
Let's consider two women writers for a
moment.
And if you've been paying attention,
you might have noticed that I haven't
talked about any women thinkers or
writers up to this point.
And in that regard,
it's important to remember that until
very recent times,
very few women had access to the kinds
of educations or were given the kind of
encouragement to engage in this kind of,
uh,
thinking or this kind of work or this
kind of reading,
uh,
as they are today.
So you might say,
ah,
it's only very recently,
uh,
that women have entered a,
this long conversation.
Uh,
why?
Because they were excluded from Jane.
Austin was a brilliant novelist and what
Jane austen wrote about were the manners
and the ways of life and the,
uh,
marriage and family arrangements of
English country gentry of the late 17
hundreds.
Now it's very unlikely that you're going
to have much knowledge about the ways of
life that were current among the English
gentry in the late 17 hundreds.
And,
uh,
that is just what makes encountering
them valuable and what makes
encountering Jane austen herself
valuable for she knows this world and
these people inside and out.
And she's an exceptional,
clever and devastating observer of the
human heart.
You come to know both the world that
these people occupied and the ways in
which they occupied this world in a way
that nature that no other author,
uh,
is ever going to reveal or take.
Another example,
Emily Dickinson.
Now,
Emily Dickinson was one of the two or
three master poets that the United
States has produced.
She had an even more narrow and an even
stranger world to show us consisting
primarily of the workings of her own
mind and her emotions,
which were exceptionally focused and
intense.
It was Dickinson or virtual reckless who
said partying is all we know of heaven
and is all we need of hell.
She also said one need be a chamber to
be haunted.
And also this,
an ear can break a human heart as
quickly as a spear.
We wish the ear had not a heart.
So dangerously near Reading Emily
Dickinson,
we'll introduce you to a mind and a
heart that simply does not work well.
Have you hearts.
It doesn't work like mine,
but she knows yours and she knows her
own as well.
Thoughts like Dickinson's and like
Austin's can dislodge us from the
everyday world.
Uh,
the things that we're familiar with,
um,
and the ways that we tend to find it
natural to think,
but isn't that the value of an education
and isn't one of the most practical
things,
um,
uh,
that,
that the world is seeking the world of
business,
the role of law,
world government,
the role of the arts,
even the world of academia,
aren't they seeking for people who take
up new and strange and different and
creative perspectives?
In other words,
isn't this takeaway from these great and
classic works maybe among the most
practical things that they have to have
offers?
My fourth value involved a building your
muscles and your reading skills and the,
uh,
the,
the ways that you're going to tackle
increasingly difficult material.
Now,
I don't think this one requires
illustration so much as it does a
reminder.
As we said,
you don't get to the Olympics by
training with weaklings and these works
have survived in part because they've
ripped,
been written by geniuses.
That is,
we know that these are mine's worth
wrestling with because so many have the
good news is that does not mean that you
have to be a genius to understand them.
Thank God.
Or I wouldn't have made it very far
myself.
Uh,
you've heard the saying,
she got to where she is by standing on
the shoulders of giants.
So here are the giants master the skills
that it takes to get up on their
shoulders and you're going to see quite
a distance.
Um,
you'll see more than they saw.
Uh,
you'll also be prepared,
better prepared to grapple with lesser
works,
uh,
that don't stand
this tall.
So for the fifth value,
I said that to the extent that you
encounter engage classic work
successfully,
you'd be a better judge of modern works.
And my example here has to be
Shakespeare.
Now,
many of the greatest critics and readers
of world literature,
including across cultures and across
boundaries,
have had the same basic view of
Shakespeare.
And that is whatever his flaws,
uh,
whatever the weaknesses and whatever the
strengths of other writers.
I know one no literary giant has ever
written more profoundly or more
inventively or more imaginatively about
the human condition than Shakespeare.
Harold Bloom,
the great literary critic critic where I
work and teach here at Yale,
uh,
called one of his books on Shakespeare,
the invention of the human.
And he meant by this,
that Shakespeare with these characters
like falstaff and hamlet and king lear
quite literally created around the year
1600 our modern sense of what it means
to be a human being,
acting and thinking in the world.
Many of his hundreds of memorable
characters,
men and women either vividly or
unexpectedly respond to their life
situations in ways that we couldn't
predict or typecast,
uh,
or they open up new perspectives on what
truly motivates each of us.
So once you have successfully engaged
Shakespeare and his,
uh,
in his comedies and in his tragedies,
you're going to very quickly since,
and other writers,
whether or not they're capable of doing
the same thing,
and if they are,
you're going to be drawn on to read
them.
And if they're not,
you can safely set them aside because
you've got a better standard,
uh,
against which to make your choices.
Let's say that you're persuaded of these
five valuable things that I say you can
take away from these work if you include
some of them on your course schedule in
college.
Could your life be better personally if
you invited some of these authors into
it?
And how so?
So think about it like this.
I shared an experience a number of years
ago when my son got involved.
Uh,
and I got involved as well in the boy
scouts.
Uh,
we hiked,
we camp,
we make friends.
Um,
W we had lots of families and the troop,
lots of other,
uh,
other adults on the trips.
Um,
uh,
it was all fine.
It was wonderful.
But then we came to a point in the
development of these young men and their
skills where we were prepared to
introduce them to something more
adventurous.
And we planned a two week wilderness
expedition,
something that we hadn't come close to
doing a with these young men before.
I was very excited.
Uh,
it was something that I had done and I
wanted my son to have the same
experience as I had had.
So let me get this straight.
He said,
we'll have to carry twice the weight on
our backs that we ever have before,
including the food.
The food is going to be pretty bad.
We're going to have to purify every
single drop of water.
We drank a,
we'll have to figure out our own trail.
It's going to be in rugged mountains.
We'll probably spend some time getting
lost.
What exactly am I going to get out of
this that I can't get from the hiking
and camping that we've already done,
which I've liked perfectly fine and
which we did without all this pain and
hassle.
Smart boy.
Good questions.
So I finally said,
you know,
I don't think I can really tell you what
you're going to get out of this.
You have to experience it for yourself.
And then you'll know.
So I guess I'm just asking you to trust
me on this.
So my son Paul certainly had some
skeptical company among the other scouts
and the troop.
And sure enough,
a few days into this expedition,
things began to deteriorate.
We had some lousy weather.
Uh,
there's blisters,
uh,
people are hungry.
Uh,
the boys are a ragging on each other.
No one's really getting along.
Um,
and,
uh,
my son,
is looking at me with those all knowing
eyes of a 16 year old.
But then the boys started to toughen up.
The weather cleared.
We got higher up in the mountains.
They started to rely on each other more.
They figured out how to break camp
efficiently.
And so one day we get to a,
a really terrific climb,
uh,
during which there was a fair amount of
complaining.
Uh,
it was a brutal effort.
And when we emerged from the,
from the tree line,
we're on top of the highest peak in the
region.
We were exhilarated.
Uh,
the boys were exhilarated and my son
came over to him and he said,
Hey dad,
I said,
what?
He said,
this is fantastic.
I said,
I know,
and he said,
I just want you to know I get it.
And I said,
what do you mean?
And he said,
this is by far the most fantastic thing
that we've ever done together.
So what did we learned by virtue of
taking a much more arduous,
a much more difficult journey than we
had taken up to that point in our
scouting experience?
Um,
well,
he's now got an experience of the
outdoors,
uh,
that's given him a permanent,
a permanent interests that he can pursue
in life.
Uh,
and of course there was also the element
of the experience that revolved around
the connection that he and I made
together by virtue of having the
experience together.
So remember what Adler said in one
sense.
Of course the great books are the most
difficult to read,
but they are in another sense the most
readable,
both for the less and the more competent
because they are the most instructive.
And that's the key word.
Obviously I do not mean says Adler most
readable in the sense of with the least
effort,
even for the expert.
I mean that these books reward every
degree of effort and ability to the
maximum.
So here's something else to think about
and it's something,
uh,
that Adler has to say and it goes beyond
the five takeaways that I gave you for,
um,
things that you've,
things of value that you can derive from
these books.
You're going to encounter a lot of
things,
uh,
in your life that you need to know and
things that you need to learn about that
aren't going to change you much at all.
Um,
you've learned many of these things
already.
You learned how to drive a car.
Uh,
but that didn't change who you were as a
human being.
I'm suggesting to you now that you're
going to be in the same position with
relation to these works.
We've been talking about in this lecture
as the scout who's done the weekend
hiking,
uh,
taking the day trip,
maybe cook breakfast,
uh,
at the camporee and so forth.
Um,
remember how I said at the beginning
that aristotle said it's our nature to
want to know things well,
just as it's our nature to work,
to play,
to find a mate to live in society.
Um,
remember how I said that wisdom is
something different from knowledge?
Well,
here's my final thought for you.
And it's a deep paradox of learning.
You don't necessarily know what you are
looking for until you find it.
And it's the effort of finding it that
actually turns you into a different
person than the one who set out on the
journey to begin with.
And that's why reading these great works
is very similar,
in fact,
to the experience that my son had of a
wilderness expedition after never having
attempted anything more than what you
can get on the low lying ground.
So when you finally do achieve a,
a radical new perspective,
when it's not just a matter of taking in
bits of information and knowledge,
but it's a matter of changing how you
put them together.
And also it's a matter of changing who
you are as a result.
Um,
you will see a different value in these
things.
And for instance,
these books,
uh,
and you're also going to see yourself in
a new light.
So I give you the only answer that I
really can,
the best answer I know
why.
Read these books.
It's the same answer I gave my son.
You climb up into the mountains,
you make your most strenuous effort.
Uh,
you give it everything have.
And what's your reward?
It's the view.
Thank you very much.